Issa Abdullah, you're on stage.
>> Hello. Hi. How How is everyone?
>> Pretty good. How are you?
>> Very well. How are you?
>> Yeah, very well, thank you. Very well,
thank you. You know,
>> we chatted before, haven't we?
>> We have chatted before. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You got a very um familiar voice.
>> Yeah. Every time I've spoken to you,
it's ended quite abruptly, so hopefully
it won't on this occasion.
>> I honestly can't remember like like I
just know that I've heard your voice
before.
>> Um so I can't remember what we talked
about before, but yeah. Um well anyway I
could hear what you were talking about
today. So I could hear you talking about
and and I just wanted to point out that
if in Arabic there is a word for if in
Arabic which is for something that's
impossible and that's the word low. Low
in Arabic is
and that's universally sort of agreed
upon and that's the word that you would
use for something that's uh that's
impossible.
>> Okay. I'm sure they can confirm that for
you. But I know it doesn't say low here.
It says in. So that is the word for if
in this occasion. So I mean I hope that
clears that up unless they are agreeing.
>> Yeah. So are you agreeing with us or
what? What are you saying?
>> Are you saying that the guy before you
lie? What are you saying?
>> No. No. What I'm saying is he was
probably mistaken with low.
>> Okay.
So that is for some that is if but for
something that's impossible and there's
lots of examples of this in the year we
have in.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So we agree that the in
means it's possible that Muhammad could
doubt grammatically.
>> Well well look what what you've got to
understand is who is saying this in the
Quran.
>> But is it grammatically is it
grammatically possible? Because remember
he was just talking about the
linguistics. He wasn't going. Well,
look, we we know that even in the
English language, you have like a second
conditional, which is something like,
you know, if I were a rich man, but I'm
not.
>> If I were a woman, but I'm not. So, when
you use the second conditional in the
English language, it's for something
that's impossible or highly unlikely.
>> I'm not saying that that's the case
here. I'm not saying
>> that's not the case here. It's not
because there are other there other
places in the Quran where it says in
where it's completely possible.
>> Yes. Yes, of course.
One second. It's just not just for you
but for everyone we're teaching. Yes. As
well. The like for example surah 16:43.
Ask the people of the message or the
people of the reminder if you don't
know. It's completely possible that you
don't know. You agree?
>> Or is it is it an impossibility they
don't know?
>> Well, look, we're jumping on to another
verse, but it's
>> we're using it's the same linguistic.
>> Yes, it's possible that they didn't
know.
>> Okay. So, it's the same word.
>> It's entirely possible.
>> It's entirely possible. Thank you. So
it's the same if it's the same if for
in.
>> It's the same if that's used for
Muhammad to possibly doubt. Correct?
>> Yes, that in is used. But what you've
got to know is Allah.
>> It's not it's not. Yes. That's all I
want to know from you grammatically.
>> It's the same. That's correct. You're
right.
>> That means possible either way.
If you are in doubt, it's not highly
unlikely or impossible. That's just the
same as it said in Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You're right. You're right.
in here is for something that's
possible. But you see the thing is in
this verse Allah saying this and does
Allah already know that if the prophet
has doubt well of course he knows
because he knows everything or not. Does
Allah know if he knowledge or not?
>> Well well in this well in the context of
this verse it's like Allah saying to
Allah saying to let me just get it up so
I can explain a little bit better. But
I'm sure you've already read the tapas
so you're probably quite familiar with
the contents of those. So
>> no, I'm happy I'm happy that you agree
with us. It's not impossible. Like your
uh brother before you've said mistakenly
>> in is not impossible.
>> That's all that's all I wanted from you
because you see that's all. So from
Yeah, he made a mistake. That's all.
>> That's okay. As far as that's what we
want to make make sure people get
correct information. That's all.
>> So uh logic or uh brother Chris or
inspiring philosophy, do you want to run
the argument by this gentleman?
>> Yeah.
Can I can I just can I can I talk about
this so we can maybe clear that up first
or
>> cuz you were just talking about it and
so 10 1094 Allah is asking saying this
to the prophet Allah already knows if
the prophet knows if the prophet doubts
or doesn't doubt
in mind
that Allah already knows this and this
this is a this
speaks about this and he says it's a
it's a way of speaking. So somebody
might say to their son, you know, if you
are my son, then obey me. It doesn't
mean that he doesn't know that you're
you're not my son. He of course he knows
that that person's his son, but this is
a this is a a manner of speaking in the
Arabic language.
>> We we get that. That's not the issue.
The issue is the first part of the
verse. So when he says to Muhammad, if
you're in doubt to go ask the people who
read the scripture before you, what is
Muhammad supposed to do if he's doubting
about the revelations he's received?
>> So yeah. Well, look, it's a conditional.
So on this instance, so he didn't doubt,
so he didn't need to ask.
>> So can I can I just make this clear
though cuz we always get hung up on the
conditional part. Whether a statement is
conditional or hypothetical or possible
or impossible is completely irrelevant
because that's not what we're getting
at. What we're getting at is that there
is something in the Quran where it says
go ask the people of the book. Now you
can say the ones that Muhammad knew and
had in his area.
>> No, to ask the people of the book that
became Muslim and they
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, I don't think
that's okay. That's fine. Let's go with
the opinion. Let's let's go with that.
Fine. It's completely irrelevant because
what we're trying to establish is that
the scriptures to which they would have
had and held in the seventh century are
authoritative. So whether they became
whether they were like Jews that became
Muslim like Abdullahbam or whatever or
whether they were Christians that became
Muslim, it's irrelevant because what
this verse is saying is you can go to
them because they have knowledge of that
previous scripture. So it's irrelevant
whether they're Muslim now or not. They
they could be seek now for all we know.
Like it doesn't make any difference to
the claim. The claim in the Quran very
clearly in 1094 and elsewhere is that
there is an authoritative command to ask
the people of the book. Now you could
say but that never happened and it's not
even possible but that's irrelevant
because Allah has already revealed that
what you should do in this in even if
it's like a ridiculous thing he's still
saying that's what you ought to do in
this ridiculous thing.
>> Okay.
>> So so he's already given us the
information about what you what what to
what is valid from that. namely that the
people of the book are valid in this
context even if this will never happen.
>> The people of the book that are valid
are the ones that became Muslim and
>> who have access to the Torah in the in
the seventh century.
>> Why would he be asking the people from
the book in the first place? Because
>> because they can confirm the revelation
of us because knowledge came to them
about our prophets prophethood. So his
description is mentioned in their
scriptures.
>> Right? So there is a valid authoritative
way to which the the Quran is telling
people to go to the people of the book.
>> So this was offered as consolation to
the prophet because obvious he was sad
that people weren't becoming Muslim and
people were saying that oh you're not a
prophet. So it was
>> because they didn't find description in
the scriptures. So, so he so he was
asked go and ask the people of the book
which people of the book the ones that
became Muslim and the ones that became
Muslim they know that the prophet our
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his
his description is mentioned in their
book
>> okay so the book is authority that
>> wait hold on hold I just want to be
clear on this one point though because
you keep referring to this
interpretation as as if it's the only
interpretation you listed a number of
commentators are you aware that your
interpretation is not the only
interpretation given.
>> Well, of course, there's always been
>> don't just keep asserting it like that's
the only interpretation on the table.
There are other interpretations on the
table. There are just general
statements. These are the people of the
book. It doesn't specify whether they
believe in Muhammad or not. But that's
irrelevant to the to the the main point
that they're making is which is that the
book is what's in authority and that is
what and and that has the ability to
resolve Muhammad's conditional doubt or
potential doubt or theoretical doubt. Do
you agree?
>> So, so look, you said you said there are
other opinions which you haven't
mentioned, but I've just told
>> I No, I did mention.
Yeah, I did give the opinion. I did. I
did. I told you I told you by what's
this guy's name? What's this guy's name?
>> Isa. Isa. So, okay. Abdullah. Okay. So,
uh I did. I don't know if you heard me.
I'll say it again. I said that there are
other interpretations that don't specify
that these are believers in Muhammad. It
just says that these are the people of
the book. For example, this is the
interpretation of mujahed. Mujah said
that these are just the people of the
book. It doesn't specify that they're
believers in Muhammad. So I did say
that. Now the overall point and I don't
know if you agree on what
>> can I respond to that also has the mujah
also has the opinion that it is the
scholars
>> that that it is the people of the books
that became Muslim so you scholars have
more than one opinion
>> yeah did you not understand my point my
entire point was that your
interpretation is not the only
interpretation that's on the table that
there are other views so when you just
keep saying your view over and over
again as if that's representative of
what all the all the scholarly opinions
are it's not true. So by you just by you
acknowledging this point it I just want
to see how honest you're going to be
with us. Now let's move past that. Okay.
I want to ask you this now. Do you
agree? Do you agree? Do you agree that
the Bible is being placed as an
authority? It has this position where it
can resolve Muhammad's potential doubt.
Do you agree with that?
>> To to him to himself?
>> Yes. Yeah. To himself.
>> Well, look, like I said, this is a
manner of speaking in the Arabic
language.
>> Okay. Look, don't tell me about the
Arabic language. Don't tell me about the
Arabic language. I'm asking you a I'm
asking you a question because you don't
know what you're talking about. You
don't know what you're talking about.
The manner of speaking in the Arabic
language is any language. The manner of
speaking in the Arabic language is like
any language is to is to convey a
meaning.
>> So this is the question and we can ask
you the same question in Arabic or in
Eru or whatever Punjabi language you
speak. The question, the question is,
the question is, is the Bible being
placed as an authority so that it can
resolve Muhammad's doubt? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Okay. Then, how? How? How is that not
the case?
>> So, when it says,
>> hold on.
>> Oh, he's he's
>> No, I'm still here, aren't I?
>> Sorry. God loic's on the stream. He's
not looking happy.
>> Oh, sorry. I missed I was mistaken when
I saw uh
>> Hello. Sorry.
>> You're here. Go ahead. explain to us
what 1094 means if it doesn't mean what
it obviously means.
>> So like I've already I mean I thought
I'd already done that.
>> Don't say a matter of speaking. Don't
say a manner of speaking because I'm
going to lose my mind. What does it mean
if it doesn't if it doesn't mean that
the Bible is an authority?
>> No they your words it doesn't say that
the Bible's an authority.
>> What it is saying is ask the people of
the book who have become Muslim. The
scholars say become
stop lying. We already
>> guys once again this is this is what
this is what the Quran this is what the
Quran
>> actually condemns Jews and Christians
for doing distorting the meaning
changing the meaning adding our own
interpretations and so on
>> with our speech twisting the scriptures
with our tongue and it's exactly what
Muslims do. He just did it. He just did
it in front of everyone.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, here's what it's saying. That's not
what it's saying. You just added a bunch
of words to twist it into something that
you want to say. Do you how I don't I
don't get it. If the Quran says Jews and
Christians are unbelievers if they do
this and then you do the exact same
things that the Quran says we're
unbelievers if we do and you do them.
How do you not get it when we call you
guys apostates?
>> So this is what's mentioned in the books
of
>> taps. Aha. Treating other books as if
they're what? As if they're the speech
of Allah and not the actual Quran. What?
That's what 279 condemns condemns Jews
for doing. And you're doing it over and
over again. Every single thing the Quran
says Jews and Christians do with their
scriptures and actually condemns us for
is what Muslims do. Every time we bring
up the Islamic dilemma, it's it's it's
amazing. It's an amazing argument, guys.
>> You have to you have to understand
everything looking at in of the entire
body of knowledge. You can't just
>> Okay. Can I ask you a log can I ask you
a logical question? How does it help
anybody's doubt? If I only ask the
people who join my religion,
>> how does it help? because they know
>> that the prophet is mentioned in their
scriptures. So they would appeal to
their scriptures.
>> Thank you. That puts their scripture as
the authority. Thank you very much.
>> You just admitted our scriptures are
authoritative. That's how Muhammad can
know that his revelations are in line
with them. That's the whole point.
You're in the Islamic dilemma.
>> I think it's the other way around. The
Quran's the authority over those books.
>> What? Wait, what?
>> The Quran is the authority over the Oh
my goodness. Dude, read the verse again.
It says, "If you're in doubt about what
we have revealed to you, what was
revealed to Muhammad?" The You say it's
the Quran, right? The Quran is revealed
to Muhammad. It says, "If you're in
doubt about that,
>> then go to
>> then you go to people who are going to
be consulting another book."
>> So what you say?
>> So if you have a consultant, if you go
to a consultant, that consultant becomes
the authority.
>> If I'm referring to someone to a
consultant, that consultant is now the
authority. So the book, the Quran is in
doubt. Muhammad, his prophethhood is in
doubt. How is he supposed to clear that
up? He's supposed to go to these
consultants who are going to the book
that you just said is their scripture.
>> Yeah. Because you said Muhammad was all
sad and Allah wanted to console him. So
he consoled him by saying go to the
people with the authoritative book
before you. He didn't say go to Quran to
console you, did he? So if he's in doubt
about his prophethood, you've got to
remember that, you know, he he would be
hearing like as he mentions that uh you
know, he mentions whisperings of the of
the devil and things like that. So
>> Oh, the devil whispered to wait the
devil whisper to your Muhammad.
>> Well, the devil whispers to everyone,
doesn't he?
>> What did he remember?
>> What did he whisper to your Muhammad?
>> I don't know.
>> Nothing doubt in his mind.
>> Okay.
>> Making him feel despair. So when when
the devil whispers to your Muhammad
instead of Allah telling him to go to
the Quran who's meant to be great he
told them to go to the previous
scripture
>> not to the previous scriptures it
doesn't say go to the previous
scriptures
>> go to those who read the book yeah read
the book of what's special about those
people
>> in the book what's special about that
book
>> the only thing that's special about that
book is the fact that it mentions of the
coming of another prophet
>> okay
>> description is mentioned in those
>> so it's authority it Even wait even
dishonest.
>> Yeah know you know you're just taking
the m is our book authoritative in how
it mentions Muhammad or not that's the
problem.
>> Let's imagine you don't let's imagine
you don't you're in doubt about
something you're uncertain and I say to
you oh why don't you go and ask this
other person too cuz he knows about it
as well. It doesn't mean that person's
authority
does. That's exactly what that means.
>> It doesn't it means that
sounds like Daniel Pikachu. It
>> it doesn't mean that. What it means is
that person will confirm what what you
already know to be.
>> Are you guys okay?
>> Already told you.
>> I just Are you guys okay?
>> We're good.
>> Not not you guys. The them the the
>> They're not okay.
>> Are y'all good, bro? It it it's almost
like y'all's brain when it comes to
Islam is shattered. It It turns off. But
I bet you if somebody else came claiming
the same thing you're claiming but the
opposite that their new book is the
authority over your Quran
>> that if we're doubting that new book go
check the Quran that came before it.
You'll be like see Quran's the
authority. Even your book says it. Like
you guys don't you guys don't you have
no self-awareness of how dumb y'all
sound. Bro,
>> it doesn't mean that we sound dumb just
cuz you're saying that we sound dumb. It
sounds like you're adding to be honest
what you're saying. Doesn't mean that
you guys sound dumb just cuz I said it.
You guys sound dumb because you sound
dumb, bro.
>> Yes.
>> I don't have to say it. I'm just I'm
just
>> understand this verse and and I think
you don't understand this. You have a
particular understanding of this word
and that's what you want to project on
it.
>> What does it mean? What does it mean to
ask those who are before you? What does
it mean to ask those who've been reading
the scripture before you?
>> Shame on you, Avery, for thinking Allah
means what he says. Don't you twist
everything he says and distort it with
your tongue? Don't you realize that
>> I should be doing that? That's how that
that's how I can understand the Quran.
Yeah, that's the only way to understand.
>> What does it mean? What does it mean to
ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you? What does that
mean?
>> Well, I've just been chatting to them
about that and I've already explained to
ask those people of the book, the
scholars of those people of the book,
the ones that have become Muslim about
the prophet signs in their book.
>> What book? What book are they going to?
>> Well, yeah, that would be the the Torah
and the Injil. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> So according to according to the verse,
you need to go to people who are aware
of what the Torah and the Gospel say to
clear up whatever doubts you might have
in the Quran. Right?
>> If you have a doubt,
>> good condition.
>> The Torah and Gospel are authoritative.
>> And then and and inb
doubt. So he didn't need to ask. Hey,
>> this is Allah already knows if he had
doubt.
>> I appreciate you for coming, man. Go
ahead and watch your clip back, man. Go
ahead and watch this clip back.
Recollect, you know, re-evaluate. Look
at this. He's gone. I
>> I thought you said the devil whispered
in his ear, so he did doubt.
>> We agree. We Yeah. And by the way, we we
agree. We could all agree on that. The
devil definitely was talking to Muhammad
a lot. Um
>> not like the Alzot were talking to
Muhammad, but
>> yeah. Yeah. There were there I mean,
yeah, there little overlap there, but no
guys, just just think about I mean, we
we go to a verse and we go to the
obvious meaning of the verse. If you are
in doubt as to what we have revealed to
you, ask those who read the book before
you. Right? And we go with a clear
obvious meaning. What do they they start
instantly adding words.
>> My goodness.
>> It's if you're in doubt,
uh, ask people who've converted to Islam
but who still know the book and we'll go
we'll go with that. And it's like, okay,
that's fine. And it's only to ask about
prophecies about Muhammad that are in
the Bible. Where does it say any of
that? They're constantly adding things.
Guys, if you believe that you can take
anything Allah says and just add a bunch
of words and change it to that meaning
when it's convenient, then fine. What
What can you point to in the Quran where
we couldn't do that and get a completely
different meaning?
>> Don't don't commit sherk unless you want
to. See, I just added words to it and
unless you want to then commit all the
sherk you want and you'll go to heaven
forever. If are we just allowed to add
words? That's what you guys are doing.
And that's exactly what the Quran
condemns Jews and Christians for doing.
How do you not get this? A four-year-old
could get this. And you take the entire
um and the entire UMA can't get it. Even
if he was right, it was only referring
to people of the book that converted to
Islam, which wouldn't make sense because
they wouldn't be people of the book
anymore. They would be Muslims. But
okay, let's just say that it's still
saying go to them. They understand what
the Torah and the Gospel, the Christian
Scriptures. That's going to verify that
your revelations are true. that's the
authority. And for him to say that
wasn't the authority, that that doesn't
mean that's an authority is just going
against basic logic. Like basic logic.
>> It's being dishonest. That's what it is.
>> He knows what it is. He knows what it
is.
>> Hey guys, you know what? You know what I
find absolutely most amazing in all of
this, and this is probably a point that
we should be bringing up in the future.
I mean, take take someone like Daniel
Hikachu, right? Famously refuses to
reinterpret passages of the Quran,
right? Like keep in mind guys uh Muslims
you you've been hearing all your lives
that according to the Quran Jesus never
died by crucifixion. That's one verse of
the Quran. That's one Quran verse which
is seriously ambiguous which even seems
to contradict another verse of the Quran
surah 3:55 which really really sounds
like it's saying that Jesus died and
which there's always been a minority
Muslim position that the Quran surah
4:157 isn't denying the crucifixion that
it's saying something else. saying that
the Jews didn't have victory over him or
expose him as a false prophet. But you
guys won't budge on that interpretation
of one verse. Um, wife beating in Islam.
Daniel Hiku won't budge on it's one
verse wife beating. You got hadith and
so on, but it's one verse of the Quran.
Hakeiku won't budge on that. You take
all these verses, he won't they won't
reinterpret any of them. Even if they're
even if it's like 41 157 is wide open
for reinterpretation, they won't budge
on their interpretation. suddenly we'll
say, "Hey, here's 150 verses of your
book confirming our scriptures." And
they'll reinterpret all of them
instantly in completely absurd ways
where Allah is the worst speaker ever.
And it's like, wait a minute, how do you
guys how are you guys the ones who won't
reinterpret things which which should be
reinterpreted? And then you'll take all
these verses over here and you'll just
you'll become the instant kings of
reinterpretation. And you'll tell and
you'll say to us over and over again,
Allah means the exact opposite of what
he keeps saying. And to do that, we'll
add words and we'll distort it and we'll
go outside the Quran to other books and
say that this is what Allah's this is
the real speech of Allah, not the Quran.
I I don't know what to do here. Allah's
perfectly clear book always confuses
everyone who reads it. I don't get it.
>> It's weird stuff, man. This is weird
stuff. Kings of reinterpretation on any
issue they just don't want to believe.
So So that So guys, the the fundamental
rule as far as what we're seeing from
Muslims is whenever Allah says something
and you want to agree with him, say yes.
That means exactly what he says. No, no
reinterpretation. Whenever Allah says
something you don't like or you you'd
rather not believe, you can just say,
"Yep, he means the opposite. We'll just
add words. We'll distort it. We'll we'll
go to other books and so on. Lovely.
>> Lovely. Picking and choosing what you
want to believe and adding words and
it's all exactly what the Quran says
Jews and Christians are going to hell
for doing. You're all doing it.
>> Well, let's uh let's see what we get,
man. Let's see if somebody can I I like
this, man. I I I just really love 1094,
man. I really do. Um I I I like I said
before, 547 used to be my favorite
verse. Let the people of the gospel
judge by what Allah's revealed in it.
And if you don't, you're, you know, a
wrongdoer. But 1094
just takes it puts it on another level.
If you doubt in the Quran, you got to
come to us. That is, that right there
was just some crazy work. Allah, I know
they wish Allah never said it. They're
like, "Allah, why you say that?"
>> Yeah.
>> Why' you have to say that, Allah? We
could have we could have spent all 547.
We could have put a spin on Why' you
have to say this? Like why, man? You
could have you could have just had a
private conversation with Muhammad. You
didn't have to put that in the Quran,
man.
>> It feels good.
>> It feels good being authorities over the
Quran, doesn't it? We're the final
authority. We are the final authorities
on whether the Quran
>> is a book from God or not. So, Muslims,
your book makes us the final authority
on whether your book is from God. So,
show us respect. Show us respect when
you talk to us. And don't lie to us.
We're not having that. You're not going
to come to us and lie to us about your
book that we decide whether it's from
God or not. Not going to happen. Not
going to happen.
>> And if you and if you don't like 1094,
just take Daniel Hakiku's advice advice
and go to surah 217 as well, which shows
that as well. So, thank you, Daniel, for
making sure.
Another good one. Another good one as
well.
>> So, I I I have a confirmation of what
Ava was saying, and it's actually a
mathematical miracle. So, IP, I want to
see you debunk this. Okay. It's a
mathematical miracle. Ready?
>> How do you know that 1094 is twice as
good as 547? Because 547
>> Oh my god.
>> So there you go. Much
>> that is the proof.
>> That's the proof. It's the better
argument.
>> Numerical miracles in the Quran
confirmed.
>> I want to see IP do a reputation video
for that.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I can't. Fits in the proof.